socialiste on écoute tout de suite sa
déclaration et encore ces dernières
semaines à l'occasion des élections
cantonal qui m'ont permis grâce à vous
de rester président du conseil général
de notre département avec une majorité
élargie c'était pour moi
indispensable si je voulais aller plus
loin grâce à
vous car ma démarche elle est de l'ordre
de l'évidence
de la simplicité de la clarté c'est en
effet ici par le suffrage que je tire ma
légitimité et la force de mon
engagement comment pouvais-je
prétendre à la plus haute responsabilité
du
pays si un jour elle m'est confia si je
n'avais pas au préalable la confiance de
ceux qui me
connaissent alors
désormais c'est de la France qu'il
s'agit notre pays notre grand pays un
pays dont nous sommes
fiers fi à la fois des valeurs qu'il
porte des astouts qu'il recèent et des
capacités humaines qu'il
contient fier de la diversité des hommes
et des femmmees sur l'ensemble du
territoire diversité qui a toujours fait
notre richesse
fier du lien
social qui a donné à notre pays dans son
histoire la cohésion qui lui a permis
d'avancer c'est pourquoi je n'accepte
pas l'état dans lequel la France
aujourd'hui se trouve et je n'accepte
pas davantage la situation qui est faite
aux
Français je ne résous pas à ce
pessimisme à cette difficulté
individuellement collectivement notre
avenir je refuse la division siamment
entretenu par un pouvoir qui joue avec
le feu en attisant les antagonismes et
les peurs je refuse
l'injustice les inégalités de revenus de
patrimoine aggraveré encore par des
faveurs fiscales au plus
privilégiés je ne supporte pas
la souffrance dans laquelle vivent trop
de nos concitoyens harassés qu'ils sont
par tant de difficultés par tant
d'amputation de leur pouvoir d'achat je
n'admets pas la violence qui
s'intensifie signant d'ailleurs l'échec
des discours répétés sur
l'insécurité et je ne m'en réjouis pas
aujour au moment où je m'exprime
apparaî direction sans cap et pire
encore sans morale avec les risques
d'une fuite en avant périlleuse dans une
forme de sauf qui peu de la part d'un
président en fin de
course voilà pourquoi j'estime que le
moment est venu de mettre la France en
avant mettre la France en avant c'est
lui donner un projet productif qui
mobilise les forces du travail mais
aussi de l'épargne les acteurs publics
état collectivité locale pour bâtir les
emplois de demain et préparer notre
avenir mettre la France en avant c'est
faire le Paris de la jeunesse de son
éducation de sa qualification de son
insertion de son orientation de son
entrée dans la vie de son accès au
logement de la réussite de la jeunesse
dépend aussi la nôtre et c'est pourquoi
il faut qu'il y ait ce pacte entre les
générations qui permettent à la France
d'avancer mettre la France en avant
c'est faire le choix de la justice
fiscale sociale territoriale c'est de
naband d'abandonner personne ni aucun
quartier ni aucun espace en métropole
comme on NRE ma et de faire en sorte que
chacun puisse se sentir ici en France
à l'égal de
l'autre mettre la France en avant c'est
réconcilier c'est rassembler c'est unir
autour des principes républicains la
dignité humaine la liberté mais aussi la
laïcité qui ne doit pas être un sujet de
débat et encore moins un pugila mais un
ensemble de règles qui s'impos à tous
mettre la France en avant c'est porter
un message fort en Europe celui de la
suprématie de la démocratie sur les
marchés c'est porter un message clair
dans le monde celui des droits de
l'homme celui de l'émancipation des
peuples mais de le faire avec constance
cohérence et
resp voilà chers amis ce qui attend la
gauche et les
socialistes ils ont cette responsabilité
les socialistes que de montrer la
direction c'est un moment
exceptionnellement difficile pour notre
pays la gauche doit se situer à la
hauteur des enjeux sinon le pire est à
craindre
l'extrémisme la
défiance la
résignation la gauche doit être à la
hauteur de la tâche qui lui est confiée
elle doit dire la vérité et en même
temps elle doit lever une espérance
écrire une nouvelle page de notre
histoire ouvrir une période de
changement et de progrès et de montrer
qu'un chemin est possible que la France
peut avancer et surtout d'offrir à la
génération qui vient après
nous un avenir meilleur que le nôtre une
vie
meilleure j'estime qu'il n'y a plus de
temps à perdre il y a même urgence il
faut à un moment que il y ait des idée
et une incarnation du changement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle ici à Tul
devant vous mes amis j'ai décidé de
présenter ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle à travers la primaire du
Parti socialiste
[Applaudissements]
l'issue fr président frçis président fr
président en
président
président Président permettez-moi de
rajouter un
mot un
seul c'est que l'issue de cette primaire
qui prépare l'élection
présidentielle doit être la meilleure
non pas simplement pour le Parti
socialiste non pas seulement pour la
gauche mais pour la France ce qui nous
attend ce n'est pas une compétition
entre nous ce n'est pas simplement de sa
voir qui et pourquoi c'est d'être
capable de donner à la France et la
fierté qu'elle mérite et au français la
confiance qu'ils attendent
[Applaudissements]
merciironsoironsoirir S